thank you
um
[Music]
it's hard to take action
it's painful
washing the dishes isn't fun
meditation can be tedious
waking up early is hard
the discomfort we feel in the face of
action often paralyzes us from doing
anything at all so we sleep in
we get lost in the rabbit hole of
youtube tik tok instagram letting
clickbait decide for us what our next
move will be
while our lives slip into disarray
we resign to inaction as the solution to
avoid the pain of action subconsciously
aware of the fact that our stagnation
breeds destruction by avoiding the pain
of action we allow something worse to
fester
the horror of watching opportunities
pass us by our relationships grow
distant our bills stack up our families
grow old
pain is all around us
it's as much a part of life as death
itself no matter how impoverished or
affluent your upbringing pain is
inescapable it'll follow you wherever
you go and this sobering reality leads
many into nihilism and despair but not
everyone knows that there's another way
to look at things pain can be bargained
with
it takes from us but it can also give
back it just depends on which pain we
choose to embrace
there are two types of pain the pain of
action and the pain of inaction the pain
of action is blunt in your face and
forces you to grow
for every hour we suffer through
sharpening our skills being proactive
and restoring order we don't reduce the
amount of pain we face but rather we
take it on the chin we sign up for it up
front and because of this voluntary
acceptance day after day we gain the
strength to shoulder it by embracing
pain instead of running from it we are
simultaneously transformed by it we
become someone we are proud of someone
that others can depend upon which in
turn gives meaning to the pain and it's
this feeling of growth and progress that
helps us feel useful to ourselves useful
to others which gives the suffering a
purpose
[Music]
the pain of inaction however
is the pain that eats away at you
a poison
it's slow burning
draining your will and decaying your
soul
by descending into apathy things
disintegrate
entropy
by letting ourselves go we lose
self-respect
negligence by vegging out on the couch
for days on end things fall into
disorder
inaction is the holiday of fools who
trade temporary discomfort for long-term
existential suffering
so which pain will we choose
action is a life-giving breath
inaction is a slow death
[Music]
hey guys if you liked the video um and
you resonated with a message then
consider checking out the new merch that
we just redesigned we made this new
merch line and dedication of this
concept in action is a slow death which
has kind of been the unofficial official
slogan of better ideas for a long time
and i really wanted to put a lot of time
and effort into this video to kind of
send that message to really
flesh out this whole concept that
inaction is a slow death so if you want
to rep in action as a slow death on your
person consider checking out the merch
it'll only be available for a limited
time so
as of the time of posting this video you
have three weeks to get your pre-order
in and you're not obligated to buy the
merch to support the channel your
viewership is more than enough you know
your likes your comments your engagement
and just showing up every single video
it blows my mind how much support this
channel gets thank you guys uh check out
the merch if you want to and if you're
hurting for cash please don't but uh i
think it looks cool this is your
opportunity if you are to buy better
ideas merch now is the time because
it'll be gone so thanks so much guys
we'll catch you in the next video